new in theaters this weekend spider-man
far from home and in theaters later this
month The Lion King well you see this is
your weekend ticket
[Music]
putting a trip go to Europe school trip
your suit I just want to go on my trip
with my friends Europe doesn't really
need a friendly neighborhood spider-man
spider-man far from home the whips onto
the big screen this weekend
this movie is both the sequel to
spiderman homecoming and the 23rd maybe
and the Marvel Cinematic Universe oh I
think she likes me when I first went
alone you're a very difficult person to
contact spider-man taking place after
the events of Avengers endgame
spider-man played by Peter Parker played
by Tom Holland finds himself being
recruited by the very pushy Nick Fury
wall on a school trip in Europe
Spidey must team up with Mysterio to
take down the elementals don't know what
I'm talking about search for it on the
web this is mr. bet we're gonna use
someone like you on my world new world
Vic is from Earth just not Alice a snap
to our home in our dimension this movie
is for you if you like any of Tom
Hollands performances as spider-man you
marvel at the Marvel movies or you
always wanted to take a trip to Europe
fun MJ I am spider-man no of course not
I mean it's kind of obvious okay what
are you doing we're in the middle of a
show right now what it's summer movie
season I'm having a summer treat hmm
this Sour Patch Kid blizzard from the
summer blizzard menu is so good come on
summer movies summer blizzard menu the
perfect pairing fine take your time
holding for Blizzard everyone yeah
[Music]
another great summer movie coming out
later this month is the Lion King
this photorealistic computer animated
movie is a remake of the original 1994
Disney classic and features the same
story of a young lion prince who flees
the kingdom and later returns to avenge
his father runaway Simba
and never returned after the success of
Jon Favreau's live-action The Jungle
Book he was asked to direct this movie
so you know it's money baby you're so
money and you don't even know it because
when I could find funders could you not
mess with them right now this movie is
for you if you like the original Lion
King donald glover AKA childish gambino
is the new voice of Simba's got you
roaring or you like cats
that is your weekend ticket what will
you see and check back next week for
more summer treats
[Music]